ausflug auf meine lieben freunde
herzlich willkommen heute zum dritten
teil von fla geraten mit sandersdorf
nachname alter als erste
schweizer schweiz
ist es dass die schweiz das ist richtig
heute sind wir alle
irgendwie so ein bisschen so von den
dingen ich glaube dass peru
das können wir die seien aber
damit geben panamera
[Musik]
dass die 22 flaggen einen ähnlichen aber
voll schön ja übel man sich jetzt an der
flanke das geld bisschen größer ist weil
es eine helle farbe ist deswegen weiter
das den raum passen
oder keine einschlagen kann der raum ich
würde sagen das ist kolumbien in
kolumbien ja ja ja mauritius
schön voll stellt das land wo auf rote
flagge auf süßes gott länder auf das ist
nicht
ihr leid ist grün gelb orange ich glaube
das wird auf jeden fall zu
großbritannien zu den harten ganzen
verschiedenen ländern das oder nicht
verstanden warum das nicht eins ist aber
trotzdem einzel nordwest
wales ja aber
das sind die vitrinen sind
aber schön
zwanziger
viele
schöne feste gerät und so
hieß es israel
zu reisen oder ein sterben dann ist das
familien
familien oder das ist winter kann polen
zusammen
was schön ist
singapur
singapur singapur es wird gesprochen was
war nochmal mit rasieren meine frage
weil die welt jahr und ist
was kommt ist
eine krankheit
auch was so ist es ja er glaube auch
nicht dass sie
das falsch
luxemburg
[Musik]
ich gehe ich sage wo erhält die ware
dass wir mal hin fliegen wollte wusste
immer was
in der karibik wo er muss niemals fluch
der karibik und tierarten im vorgarten
ich gerade schon beim thema wie geraten
würden weil im ihn freuen ich habe neun
spielen 36 wieder spiel heißt nähe world
of more schlimmste was geht es da keine
sorge sage ich dir jetzt soll der chip
ist ein kostenloses strategie spiel das
man am pc gegen andere spieler oder
freunde online spielen oder forschung
bietet über 400 verschiedene
schiffsmodellen die man auch noch selber
nach seinem belieben anpassen kann ihr
könnt dabei eure schiffe auch
unterschiedlichen maps und in
verschiedensten landschaften steuern von
mit oder gegeneinander antreten
aufgeregt mit meinem link in der infobox
und dem kot boom
was kriegt man damit ja wahrscheinlich
irgendwo einen rabattcode dahlan
kostenlose starter paket im wert von 25
euro und weißwasser an alles beinhaltete
202 schild und zwar die saint louis und
das premium schiffen 20 rest des bayer
camouflage 2,5 millionen credits und
sieben tage premium version der code
gilt aber nur für neue registrierungen
wargaming portal also wenn du dich
dennoch anmeldest kannst du ein code
benutzen 520 euro staaten mit allen den
sachen die ich gelesen habe aber jetzt
geht es weiter mit dem nächsten
flug
eines katers das ist
so wenig
dass sie gar nicht gesagt ist hübsches
findet die hässlich doch dies aber erst
los wenn man die hübsche würde ich habe
jetzt mal gesagt dass die klage nicht
sinnvoll habt beginnt jede frage gefüllt
außerdem
was ist das das wieder so dass das
format nicht gecheckt haben
ein dreieck ein ich glaube nicht eine
flagge machen würde ich wird sie
komplett schwarz machen einfach wie geil
wäre das ja unser hobby eigentlich da
unser hobby archäologe
architekt also seine große leidenschaft
von japan knochen auf
wenn da mehr aber vielleicht haben wir
da schon gesagt müssen ja das war's dann
lesen wir dass kolumbien
beherzten nachhaltig genommen genau
das ist vor iran oder irak irak und
syrien
afghanistan irak
ja das ist richtig
hab jetzt also ab jetzt komplett
[Musik]
das ist dicht ich ja da habe ich raus
schritt gemacht in wales
was machen nur 60 jährige
weiter
schottland schultern das richtige
auch wieder irgendwas afghanistan syrien
iran irak das ist in den ring
ich würde sagen das hielt ich hab gerade
laufe ich würd sagen afghanistan ist da
aber schöne flagge ja sehr schön sein
wie of the flak china für dich
das ist albanien ja das ist einmal der
weg stimmt das ist richtig
was war das jetzt noch mal finnland ja
ich muss überlegen
slavia ich sag auch mirko slomka kann
wie der rapper hat die charta wie das
land hab ich ja
das ist
das ist cool und das columbia das ist
ecuador
kolumbien ecuador der kammerchor
schätze
das ist doch das mittelalter
[Musik]
das ist doch so mehr ja ich glaube diese
aktiva wegen dem drachen
ist auf jeden fall keine ahnung das land
gibt schon richtig lange was war das
erste land auf der welt ich sage das
lateinamerika und hat sich auch
das ist sri lanka
ich weiß wie lang heinz wo bei
brasilien
[Musik]
ich habe keine ahnung von mir sein kunde
kolumbien
das ist nigeria
wenn ich hier ja schon mal die für jedes
land dahin geschoben ich spiele jetzt
auch mal über 100
wir sind ziemlich scheiße ja
[Musik]
hast du nachlass zu hause hast du dir
immer aussagen den kalender okay kann
ich auch nicht so teuer des
vorwurfs auf meine liebste serviceatlas
aber so ein globus weiteres mal geil nun
muss folter einsetzen ist geguckt hat
sich arbeiten